We had gotten at the end of last time to the big Rep.
Yeah.
This is where the ever expanding cosmological constant,
which is of course a contradiction in terms.
If you imagine the dark energy is not a cosmological constant,
that it's actually increasing in time,
rips everything to shreds.
The universe becomes infinite in size and a finite amount of time and everything
gets pulled apart.
What I want to start by doing today is to go back and do that again slowly.
Okay.
Uh,
because I think this is,
this is not a,
uh,
it's not a simple line of reasoning that leads you to this.
So let's go all the way back to what we know about,
uh,
the universe from,
from observing galaxy.
Supernova is things like that.
Uh,
we know that the university is expanding,
uh,
and that we know,
Hubble already figured that out.
We know this from the Hubble law
when the Hubble law and from,
uh,
other,
just in general from the study of a standard candles at relatively low red
shift.
So,
uh,
distances out to,
I dunno,
Z of less than oh 0.2 or so.
You can't tell the difference between an accelerating or decelerating universe.
All you know is that it's expanding and you can figure out how fast it's
expanding.
Uh,
now the next question then becomes,
uh,
the rate of expansion.
Is the rate of expansion changing?
Is it,
is it accelerating?
Is it decelerating?
What's going on there?
Uh,
and so you want to compare acceleration versus deceleration,
which is a fancy word is,
you know,
for slowing down,
uh,
and deceleration,
this is a relatively easy to grasp.
Uh,
this is what,
uh,
what happens because of matter,
matter exists.
It's got gravitational force,
uh,
and gravitational force tends to hold things together.
So if you've got something that's moving apart with grout and there's some
gravitational force of will tend to hold it together and thus slow it down,
most of the matter it turns out,
is this weird dark matter,
which we don't understand.
Uh,
but,
uh,
that's what's responsible for the deceleration.
If you're going to make it go faster and you need something much weirder,
that pushes outward,
that has repulsive force.
Uh,
this we believe actually exists.
This we labeled dark energy,
hence sell the question of is it accelerating or as a decelerating is basically
a question of,
uh,
how much dark energy is there versus how much matter is there?
Because the more,
if you have more of this,
then this,
then it will accelerate.
Uh,
and vice versa.
And what we have discovered by a supernovae observations with red shifts,
uh,
greater than oh 0.3 and a buy now out to about a,
about a red shift of one or so,
uh,
demonstrate that.
Well,
what exactly does this sec?
Let's go slowly.
Uh,
in the past,
uh,
the universe
was expanding
more slowly than it is now.
And therefore those three dots are the mathematical symbol for therefore,
therefore the universe is accelerating
and therefore there's more dark energy
there.
There is matter.
Okay.
And you'll recall we did the little pie chart of the universe and it turns out
it's three quarters dark energy in one quarter matter.
Uh,
and,
uh,
those proportions are determined by,
the,
uh,
rate at which the universe is accelerating.
Not The rate at which it's expanding,
but the rate at which it's accelerating because that's the change in the
expansion.
Fine.
So far.
Uh,
or maybe it isn't fine.
I should,
I should pose that as a question.
Fine.
Uh,
this is the basic,
uh,
premise of where we had gotten to about a week ago.
Yes,
sir.
Hold on a minute.
Hold on.
How Dark Energy Causes Acceleration?
Excellent question.
I have no idea,
uh,
because we don't have any idea what it is.
Uh,
and,
uh,
it shows up.
The reason we have even a name for it,
you know,
is that it is that it showed up in Einstein's equation as a potential
contribution to the universe,
uh,
that you,
that you could add but didn't have to,
uh,
constant of integration for those of you who like that kind of thing.
What it is physically very hard to understand.
The only physical explanation that's been offered,
well,
many had been offered,
but the only one that,
uh,
connects to anything else we know is the idea that it's the vacuum energy
predicted by quantum mechanics.
And it turns out that if that's true,
it ought to be 10 to the hundred and 20 times stronger.
Uh,
and so that's not a good prediction.
and so exactly how this works,
what the mechanism is,
what the nature of this stuff is completely unknown.
And the only reason we think it's there is that we see it to fact we see the
universe getting faster.
And so it's just a name that's attached to whatever is causing that effect.
Okay?
Yes.
University
was expanding more slowly than it is now.
Right?
So that is,
uh,
this,
transformation between these two different kinds of graphs,
one of which is the observed graph.
And one of which,
uh,
is the,
is the plot of the scale factor versus time.
Here's now,
here's one.
We're at one and now.
And so if it were not,
uh,
accelerating,
if it were just going on,
coasting along with that would be a straight line.
And a,
what happens is we can look back into the past and what we see is this.
So at this point,
if you think about it,
believe me for a sec,
that this is true.
Supposing you were sitting here,
what the,
the rate of expansion is the slope of this line.
That's how much you're expanding.
And so at this point,
the slope is shallower than it is up here.
And so,
uh,
one interpretation of this line is that in the past used to be expanding,
you know,
like this,
and now it's expanding like this.
Ah,
how do you,
how do you know it's doing that particular shape?
Uh,
well,
uh,
you of course observe points all along the way here.
Uh,
now,
uh,
we're about to get to the question of whether that shape actually continues.
Uh,
if you ask,
how do you know that it would continue this way?
Uh,
that of course you don't know for sure if you invent some piece of magic whereby
everything changes right now.
Uh,
for some obscure reason,
it could go off in some other direction.
Uh,
but the assumption is that whatever it is,
that's,
that we do not live at a special time and that therefore,
whatever it is that's doing the accelerating is gonna keep at it.
Uh,
and indeed the whole of the big rip,
which is where I'm going with this,
uh,
comes about by asking the question.
Supposing the acceleration rate is changing in a different way from the way we
thought it was going to.
Uh,
just to complete the thought here.
the way this works out in the observational plane,
you'll recall,
looks like this.
Here's the empty universe in this set of units and you observe a bunch of
supernovae and they seem to be doing that.
And that line,
if you then,
uh,
transform,
red shift and distance,
this is kind of a weird measure of distance into a scale factor and time.
Uh,
let me make this line solid so that of course the two graphs correspond this
line and that line corresponds with each other.
And so as you observe many points along here,
that's essentially observing many points along.
Okay?
Yes.
Given the empirical data that we knew,
if we were going to scratch it,
if we were to extrapolate that curve,
it actually intersection the t axis,
or would we or would we need to have,
ah,
let me come back to that.
Let me come back to that.
The answer is yes,
it does go to zero.
Uh,
it,
it doesn't keep going up like this,
but let me come back to that in a second and you'll see why.
Okay.
Um,
so it's all a balance of dark energy
versus dark matter or matter in general,
but the dark matter predominate.
And at the moment it is true that the dark energy is a,
there's more of it.
It exerts more,
uh,
more of an influence on the universe.
Therefore,
the university's is x,
not just expanding,
but also accelerating.
We know that because these points are above the line,
not below the line.
Uh,
but this didn't always have to be true.
This balance changes with time.
Oh,
so currently,
uh,
d blows away the dam.
Uh,
but,
uh,
this can change.
This changes.
In fact,
this is almost certain to change with time.
And the reason is that the energy density of the dark energy and the matter
density of the dark matter behave differently as you change the size of the
universe.
It's all about the density here.
So matter density,
uh,
in the past,
you have the same amount
of matter,
but the universe was smaller.
Okay.
Dance city is equal to mass over volume.
So if you have the same m but smaller V,
uh,
this would have to have been bigger in the past.
And in fact goes as the scale factor cubed or one over the scale factor cubed.
Uh,
just because volume goes as a linear scale cube.
So in the past there was the,
the,
the matter density was much greater than it is right now.
And therefore the gravitational force trying to hold the universe together was
greater than it is right now.
Uh,
but the cosmological constant is constant.
And what that means is that it's density is constant.
And what that means is that in the past,
the dark energy density
was the same as it is now.
That's just the way,
uh,
this particular piece of Einstein's equations works.
It's a constant.
Uh,
now if you're about to ask the question,
well,
how does anything behave that way?
I'm going to give you the same answer.
You know,
they have this wonderful thing in the British parliament where they ask,
uh,
ask the prime minister question obnoxious questions and when they start getting
too many obnoxious questions in a row,
uh,
what he'll do is he'll look at the camera and say,
I refer the honorable gentleman to the answer I gave some moments ago.
So,
uh,
if you're going to ask what this is and why it behaves that way,
I will refer you to the answer I gave to the honorable gentleman one at some
moments ago.
Namely,
I don't have a clue.
Uh,
something they don't generally say in political situations.
Um,
alright.
Uh,
so it's the same as now.
But look at the application of this.
If the,
uh,
matter density
gets bigger and bigger and bigger as you go into the past
and the dark energy density does not,
then at some point in the past it must have been true that the matter density
overwhelms the dark energy.
And,
uh,
at some point in the past,
the dark energy and the dark matter exert comparable effects on the universe.
And before that
dark matter wins,
okay?
That is to say the universe
was decelerating.
Now turn this around and go in chronological order,
uh,
from the start of the universe
until some moment
the universe
decelerated it.
Got It.
It was expanding,
but it kept,
uh,
it kept getting slower then after
some moment.
And we know that this moment was in our past because after this moment,
it starts to accelerate.
Okay?
And we know that it's accelerating now.
Uh,
and so at some point in the past,
there was a magic moment where everything balanced and then it started to
accelerate.
So now what does this look like on our graphs?
What does this look like on the graphs here?
Well,
let's do the a versus t thing again.
Here we are.
Here's the,
uh,
here's our reference empty universe.
And so recently it's been accelerating.
So you know,
if we look into the past and then the prediction is the extrapolation back to
zero looks kind of like this.
And remember if it looks like,
if it looks like this,
it's decelerating.
If it looks like this,
it's accelerating.
And so the dotted lines or extrapolations are extrapolations based on the idea
that the dark energy is the cosmological constant and the dark matter behaves
like matter ought to behave until if you make those two assumptions,
this is the curve you get.
And so this is what you expect for Omega matter equals 0.25.
Omega Lambda equals 0.75.
Okay.
At the Er at present.
Okay
Matt.
So you can predict,
given given these two quantities and a measurement of h naughty calls about 70,
this gives you an age of the universe.
That is to say the time from when it equals zero to now
of the universe of something like 13 point.
Uh,
I think it's actually at the moment,
13.4 billion years plus or minus,
I don't know,
point for something,
something like that under the,
this,
that the assumption that lamb did equals,
uh,
that lab that the cosmological constant really is constant.
That you've got these kinds of proportions and this kind of card,
uh,
Habo constant.
And then you could just extrapolate all these lines in whatever direction you
like,
uh,
and figure out where it crosses a equals zero.
Yes.
Sorry.
Excellent question.
The question is,
can we see back far back in the past to see this deceleration?
The answer is just about yes,
and I'll show you some data in a second.
Uh,
because this is a very strong prediction of the model that is to say that it
should turn around if you're imagining that there's something wacky about
supernovae and that as you go into the past,
they look fater or something as you were assuming on the problem set,
uh,
then you wouldn't necessarily predict that that would turn around and do the
other thing as you go further back in the past.
So this is a very strong prediction of what ought to happen.
Cosmologically and so of course people have been trying to it yes.
If the density of the universe is changing,
then wouldn't that indicate that word special time right now given the fact that
the current,
if the university is really close to the critical density?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
the question is,
about if the density's changing,
why does the,
what's so unusual about,
now that we're close to the critical density,
the thing you have to remember is the critical density also changes with time.
It's based on,
remember the critical density,
it's three h squared over something or other.
Well,
h changes with time because the velocity is more or less the same,
but the distances all change.
So it's always been pretty close.
Uh,
well what is true is that,
uh,
the way it works out mathematically,
what's true is that the Somme of these two quantities has always been close to
one.
The ratio changes.
Uh,
but the sum of these two,
if the total Omika,
if the total Omeka starts as one,
it stays at one.
Uh,
but it turns out it's the total omega that you can see that is conserved.
and,
and we'll come back to that point a little later.
Okay.
Uh,
let's see.
Right?
Okay.
So,
yes,
let's go there.
Let's go,
let's go for the observational evidence.
What would you expect it to be?
Here we go.
Uh,
this one again,
we keep going back and forth between these two plots.
Uh,
it's what it's all about.
so here's empty universe has always,
uh,
and then,
in this plot,
acceleration means a positive slope.
So if you're moving up in this plot,
the universe has been accelerating,
is accelerating at that particular red shift at that particular time in the
past.
So,
you know,
the,
the data we've looked at so far kind of look like points along the line like
this.
That's the demonstration that the universe is now accelerating.
So here's the prediction.
And you know,
here's a magic moment where,
uh,
at that point,
this slope is flat.
And so,
um,
this side,
it's decelerating.
And on this side it's excellent,
right?
And the question is,
is it getting further away from,
uh,
is it moving up compared to the amputee universe?
Or is it moving down compared to the empty universe?
Because the empty universe neither accelerates nor decelerates.
That's the definition of an empty universe.
It doesn't have any mass.
It doesn't have any energy.
The excel or the expansion rate is constant forever.
So,
uh,
if you're going this way with respect to that line or going this way with
respect to that line,
uh,
you're accelerating.
And if you're coming back going in the other direction,
you're decelerating.
So here's,
here's a closed universe,
right?
Which is going to,
uh,
this is,
this is a big crunch universe,
which is going to re collapse because it's decelerating all the time.
Now,
interestingly,
this turnaround point a where you turn around between accelerating and
decelerating is not so far back into the past.
It,
so,
uh,
if,
if you believe this set of parameters,
the standard model,
it's it around oh 0.8,
we can see stuff at all 0.8.
And,
uh,
you could hope to go and see things,
even further out.
Uh,
turns out it's kind out now,
uh,
right at Oh,
if you only go out to about 0.8,
which is about as far out as the as they did for the first time round,
you're not going to see the turnaround because you know,
it's just more or less flat.
You've got a few points out there and you're going to have a tough time telling
the difference between that and that at this point here.
But if you go out just a little bit further,
you might really be able to see this turn around happening.
Unfortunately,
that turns out to be hard observation.
Uh,
it's hard to see supernovae with red shifts greater than one,
uh,
for a number of different reasons.
First of all,
their fate,
the further away they are,
the faint or they are.
Second of all,
they appear on top of galaxies.
Obviously they live in galaxies.
The further away you look,
the galaxies look smaller.
And so the supernova appear to be super.
The further away you look,
a,
the more of the Gout,
more peace,
more light from the galaxy,
the Supernova is super imposed on and it becomes harder to separate the light
from the Supernova and the light from the galaxy that it lives in.
And the third part is that the light is red shifted,
very red,
shifted,
red shifted by a factor of two.
So supernovae give off most of their light in optical light,
which we can observe.
But by the time they were a red shift of one,
all the wavelengths are doubled.
And so most of the radiation
is n the infrared,
just much harder to see from the ground because everything glows in the
infrared.
Uh,
and you've,
it's like,
look,
as I said before,
it's like looking in the day time.
The whole sky is glowing,
your telescope is glowing.
Uh,
it's just really hard to make those kinds of observations.
It is possible,
however,
to do.
It's much easier to do this from space.
Now thanked his fate.
It doesn't matter whether you're an orbiter,
not,
but the other two things are greatly aided by looking from space,
uh,
point to,
you get much better images from space.
Uh,
and you may recall last time I showed you a picture of a supernova and from the
ground,
uh,
you know,
it was a little extra light on top of some galaxy and then when you look from
space,
the galaxy was clearly delineated and then the supernova was a tiny point in the
outskirts of that galaxy.
So it makes it much,
much easier to separate,
uh,
the galaxy from the Supernova.
And it is also true that the infrared background light
is much fainter
cause you can keep stuff cold out there.
Uh,
the infrared background light as much fainter,
uh,
and there's no atmospheric absorption.
Yeah,
yeah.
Atmosphere actually absorbs a large fraction of the infrared light that,
uh,
that hits us.
Um,
that's actually why the greenhouse effect works.
Cause light comes in as optical light and it makes it all the way through.
Then it heats up the surface of the earth.
The earth radiates heat,
which doesn't make it through the atmosphere.
It gets trapped.
Um,
so,
uh,
there no atmospheric absorption out there.
And so,
uh,
you have a much easier time doing this from space.
So what they have been doing is,
uh,
recently,
people in particular guy named Adam Reece,
uh,
have been using the space telescope,
the Hubble Space Telescope to find high red shift
supernova.
This,
there is a flaw in the way the space telescope is designed from the point of
view of tried to do this experiment.
And the flaw is that it doesn't look at very much of the sky at once and only
looks at a small field of view.
Oh phew.
So you don't find many,
cause you're just not looking at that big a part of the Scott.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
you can only,
you only look at a tiny piece of the sky at once,
however they have spent,
because this is of some clear importance.
They've spent many,
many,
many hundreds of observing hours,
uh,
with the space telescope trying to track down a few supernovae at a red shift
greater than one.
Uh,
and they have now succeeded in doing so.
So here's what the data look like.
This is from Adam's recent paper,
2004,
I guess it's no longer quite so recent.
Uh,
and this is the plot.
Well,
let me see if I can focus this.
Uh,
it's actually the xerox quality.
we have a joke in astronomy that many,
uh,
important objects turned out to be a ls [inaudible],
which stands for low significant xerox transients source.
That means you've made a xerox in a little blip,
appears on your graph,
and somebody says,
what's that point in the upper right hand corner?
And you say,
oh,
that's the xerox machine.
All right,
so I apologize for that.
But look what's happening.
This is red shift.
This is the,
this is the plot we've been looking at before.
Zero Point Five,
1.0,
1.5 and two.
And this is the delta m minus m access.
So zero is what you expect,
uh,
the empty universe to have.
And he has marked on here a different set of lines from the set of lines I've
been drawing.
But nevertheless,
you can see what's going on.
Here are,
these are all supernovae,
uh,
all the Supernova,
they know,
uh,
these kinds of fuzzy gray points are the ones they found with the space
telescope.
The ones in here are the ground based ones known at the time.
And what they've done is they've,
is,
they've averaged them together in different groups of red shift grouping by
Retro.
That's the bottom thing.
So each one of these points is an average of many supernovae.
Uh,
this point is an average of these two.
and then as you get down to lower shifts where they have lots and lots of them,
the precision gets much better.
But you can definitely see what's happening here out to about,
you know,
0.5 0.8,
it's going up.
And then it does definitely seem like it's going down.
Uh,
and so there really is now some evidence for this,
for this turnaround.
Now,
uh,
it Kinda all depends on these two points.
Uh,
I have a rule of thumb.
My rule of thumb is you can put your thumb over any one point,
uh,
because you never know.
Uh,
what screw up might have happened in any one measurement.
so,
uh,
I can't really do that on the top,
but if I do this okay,
and I make that point go away,
uh,
you could still kind of draw a line that keeps going up.
Uh,
it would miss this point by a little,
but not by a lot.
Uh,
it's really this,
that does it.
It's these last two individuals supernovae down there,
which really make the case that the thing is turning over and coming back down.
Now,
uh,
you have to worry a little bit and there's actually a good reason to worry
about,
uh,
the brightnesses of high redshift.
Supernovae.
Uh,
and let me give you one particular reason to worry,
uh,
a reason to worry.
Uh,
namely gravitational lensing
member gravitational lensing.
Uh,
you stick some mass in,
in,
in the middle between you and the object you're looking at.
It focuses the light.
Gravitational lensing makes things look brighter.
The further away you look at something,
the more likely it is that there's something in between that we'll do the
lensing.
Uh,
so first of all,
0.1 more distant objects,
more likely to be lensed
0.2.
Uh,
if you're out looking for very distant,
very faint objects,
which are the ones you're going to see first,
the bright ones,
yes.
Ah,
AH,
at the sort of faint limit.
Uh,
you see abnormally bright things first.
I can't even spell that abnormally,
right?
Things
preferentially.
So you could imagine if you're basing your entire cosmology on one or two high
redshift supernovae,
you got to ask yourself the question.
Supposing those happen to be lent.
So let me now go back to this plot.
Here's the plot.
So if they're lensed,
then they're brighter than they seem to be brighter than they actually are.
They're actually fainter than they look.
That would have the effect that this one actually ought to be up here.
And this one actually ought to be up here
if they were lens by some amount.
So if these things are lenses,
then the true correct position of these points would be higher up in the graph
than it actually is.
So this is the effect of lending.
Now when it was only one of these points,
uh,
people were very concerned about this.
Now that there's two people or a lot less concerned because you know,
it would be pretty bad luck to have both of the supernovae,
uh,
that you know about it.
High redshift turnout to be lance.
If they had 20,
uh,
this whole problem would go away because there'd be no possible way that you
could be so unlucky.
Well,
you could calculate the probability that you would be so unlucky as to have the
first 20 high redshift supernovae,
you know,
happened to line up right behind some massive object.
And it would be some incredibly small probability.
So each time you observe another one of these things out here and it's low,
you get around this lending problem,
I should say,
this is only one of a number of problems.
These things are very hard to observe.
They're very faint objects.
Uh,
but nevertheless,
I think at the moment,
uh,
the,
the evidence for this turnaround is highly suggestive,
but not yet holy conclusive.
Uh,
all right.
But now suppose,
uh,
you,
you actually want to get higher accuracy than just seeing the thing turned
around because suppose dark energy
isn't constant.
Suppose,
uh,
the big rep really is going to happen then d e density increases with time.
This leads to the big rep as we discussed last time.
And therefore the dark energy density was Wes in the past,
then in now
and therefore,
uh,
the deceleration,
the moment of balance between deceleration.
Okay.
Yeah.
Uh,
between deceleration and acceleration,
uh,
was more recent
because as you go back in the past,
under this new scenario where there's,
where the density of dark energy is,
is increasing with time,
it's therefore decreasing as you go into the past.
So as you go into the past,
two things happen.
The a density of matter gets bigger and the density of dark energy gets less.
So there's an additional effect that will make that crossover happen earlier.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
to summarize on these,
by now,
uh,
almost boring and ubiquitous plots here.
All right.
Uh,
so here's,
here's the kind of standard cosmological model.
Uh,
and if it's going to be a big Oh,
and then this predicts in the future that it's going to go something like that.
If it's a big rip,
then what happens is it's doing this and it's going to do that
because the dark,
the dark matter,
uh,
takes over from the dark energy more,
more recently in the past because you've also lost oomph in your dark energy,
but the dark energy is getting bigger and bigger with time.
This then translates onto this plot.
Uh,
and here is well,
we expect it.
Here's the kind of prediction into the future,
a future,
a future of observations,
uh,
further into the past in time.
And what you would expect is that this would sort of Keel over earlier.
So this is
a big rip cosmology,
big rip cosmology has,
uh,
the same
big rip would have the same expansion rate now
the same acceleration now,
uh,
but more acceleration in the future than you expect and
more deceleration in the past.
Okay.
And so it's important not just to see this turn around,
uh,
but to actually plot in detail where that line goes.
Because if it turns out that you're,
that you're supernovae are kind of lined up like this or they're kind of lined
up like this,
you already know that there are a bunch of them like this or that they're kind
of lined up like this makes a huge difference in how you understand the dark
energy and tells you something new about the dark energy.
In fact,
it tells you the first thing you know about the dark energy.
Other than that it exists,
namely that it would be getting bigger or less big or maybe staying constant as
a function of time.
Yes.
If,
um,
if they do celebration was,
was earlier than expected,
you know,
following the big,
big rip.
Wouldn't we have seen it already since we can already see SPEC.
Ah,
so,
uh,
these three lines at about,
you know,
old 0.8 are very,
very close together.
They don't diverged all that much until a red shift until the turnaround at
about a red shift of 0.8 to one.
Now in principle,
you could go out and make a whole bunch of,
you know,
measure 10,000 of these things that are red shift to 0.5 and try and distinguish
that way.
Okay,
so how are we going to figure this out?
The space telescope kind of finds these things one at a time.
It's going to be off like puff to make this distinction.
Uh,
but let me introduce you to two projects currently underway.
The goal of which is a to figure this out.
And they,
they,
they do the exact two things that we've just been talking about.
One is designed to go deep to a high red shift.
Uh,
and the other is designed to do many,
many,
many at intermediate red shift.
Uh,
so,
uh,
there is something called the,
so there's a space mission,
a space telescope.
Uh,
this is called j Damn stands for joint,
uh,
joint dark energy mission and the joint means joint between NASA and the
Department of Energy.
Whoever named this stuff,
dark energy gets a little prize because now we get money from the Department of
Energy to study it.
Uh,
let's see.
And,
and the idea of which,
an example is something called snap one proposal.
That's the Super Nova
cosmology supernova acceleration
probe.
This is,
this is an example of one mission proposed to be jaded.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
an example.
Uh,
and,
uh,
it's an example I'm familiar with because we have people here at Yale who were
working on it.
Uh,
and there are competitors,
they haven't actually selected the thing.
Yep.
Uh,
and what is this going to be?
Is it's a space telescope that differs from the current space telescope in two
major ways.
One is it has a wide field of view,
uh,
dozens of times bigger than the current space telescope.
Cause all it can do to I,
let me see if I can remember it.
It's like 20,
it's,
it's over a hundred times bigger field of view than the current space telescope.
So the discovery rate of supernovae will be much,
much greater and it's optimized for the infrared.
And so it's goal is to find,
yeah.
Many supernovae
okay.
With red shift,
greater than one,
perhaps out to a redshift of two.
That's its purpose in life.
Uh,
and,
uh,
proposals are currently being evaluated for this launch time is supposed to be,
well the optimists say 2013,
but that means congressional funding this year,
which is actually unlikely more likely 2016 or 2017 and then we'll know.
Yes,
yes.
Sort of optimization frame.
Are there any other predictive sort of benefits of it?
Oh,
it's very nice to look at the infrared because anything at high redshift chimed
in the infrared until if you're looking at hi Richard Galaxies,
how galaxies evolve and so forth.
Uh,
this is useful too.
There's actually a big debate over whether you totally set the thing up to do
nothing but supernovae or whether you sort of generalize it and spent half your
time doing other things.
Uh,
and there's one other project at least,
which I'll describe next week that,
that these guys are interested in doing.
Uh,
but there's a real trade off between making it a general purpose telescope like
the Hubble or doing this one thing especially well.
And that's,
you know,
the kind of thing that's currently under discussion.
So snap is one example of where people might go in the future.
Another is a,
a ground based project called the large
uh,
synoptic survey telescope.
This is otherwise known as l.
S.
T.
L.
S.
The plan is this,
and this has a lot of other science beside this.
It's going to do a full skirt survey of the sky survey of the sky every three
days.
So it's gonna every three nights at marches across the entire sky cakes,
a really deep image of the sky and saw the consequence of this for cosmology is
that you find every low and intermediate,
uh,
red shift supernova that's tens to hundreds of thousands,
tens of thousands,
maybe 10,000 a year
approximately.
So you'll find lots of these things.
So first of all,
you build up incredible statistics out to a red shift of about a half.
So huge statistics,
yeah,
to z of about a half.
That's kind of where it's limit is going to kick in.
Uh,
and you also,
uh,
can study the details of subclasses of supernovae.
So this is important because you know,
if you're fooling yourself because the distance supernovae are different somehow
from the local supernovae,
their fainter for some reason.
Uh,
but in the local sample,
only one in a hundred is the of the fate kind.
If you've got 10,000,
that means you've got,
you know,
a sample of a hundred of the weird subclass that's causing your trouble.
So this will be hugely helpful,
not only in beating down the statistics so that you can tell the difference
between lines that are really quite close to each other theoretical predictions
that are close to each other.
But it also will test the systematic problems that you might have different
kinds of supernovae and generally enhance your overall confidence that you know
what you're talking about.
Also,
uh,
these kinds of sky surveys,
are of benefit for many,
many other fields of astronomy.
The issue with this is the following statistic,
uh,
30 terabytes of data per night,
right?
That's a 30,000 Gig per night,
uh,
30 million megabytes every night.
Uh,
and so this is not something that us,
normal astronomers can handle.
Uh,
and so the recent news from the LSST project is Google has joined the project a
ad.
So we're bringing in,
we're bringing in the,
yeah,
right?
Uh,
we're bringing in the big boys for this.
and I think this is kind of Google universe,
right?
Uh,
because it's,
uh,
you know,
you take all,
you do this for a few years,
then you've done a hundred sky surveys.
You can then add them all up and get incredibly deep data.
And so I guess Google figured,
you know,
if somebody is going to be a piling up a catalog of the entire known universe,
they'd better a part of it.
Uh,
and it's fortunate for us because they're probably the only people in the world
who can create a data database,
a,
of data coming in at this rate.
Uh,
and I should say,
keep in mind too,
that you have to actually not just acquire this data,
you have to actually look at it each night because you've got to actually
discover these supernovae in real time because they're going to be gone three
weeks from now or four or three months from now.
And so you not only have to pile up 30 terabytes of data every night,
you've got to actually look at it and find all the interesting object.
So,
uh,
the plan currently is to operate for a at least five and probably 10 years.
They have a site picked out,
they're going to put it down in Chile,
actually on the mountain where,
uh,
our tiny telescope is a,
and so we're,
we're actually like this because they'll pay for some of the infrastructure
costs down there.
Uh,
hopefully for all of the infrastructure costs.
But a negotiation is still in progress.
And,
uh,
they,
they have a whole design plant for this.
It's all ready to go.
Uh,
but it's going to cost a fair amount of money to build them.
What's even more important,
it's going to cost an enormous amount of money to run,
uh,
just on a night to night basis.
So actually the construction costs of the telescope or not the dominant costs,
the dominants costs are building the software and running the program.
And it turns out that's harder to get some rich guy to give you $100 million for
a and a it's ground face,
so it doesn't fall into the NASA category.
And so it isn't clear what the money is gonna come from.
They actually have a fair amount of private money already piled up there.
Uh,
they,
and as I say,
they have detailed,
elaborate plans for this thing.
You can look at their website,
uh,
in fact,
you will have to look at their website because that's going to be part of the
problem set.
Um,
and,
uh,
so these are two of the projects which are currently,
being designed.
And hopefully soon we'll be built,
uh,
that are going to try and push this a little further and try and find out more
about the dark energy than simply the fact that it exists.
Okay.
Um,
let me put back up this,
uh,
a piece of paper with details.
Remember no sections on Monday,
no sections on Monday.